so we need to find the cube root of
negative
343. another way to think about this
this is the same thing as
negative 343
to the one third power or another way of
thinking about it if x to the third is
equal to negative
343 so let me write if
x to the third is equal to negative 343
then
x is equal to the cube root
of negative
343. so these are all ways of viewing it
we're this is essentially saying there's
some number when i multiply it by itself
three times i should get negative 343.
so let's figure out what this number is
and the easiest way i can think of doing
it is to do a prime factorization of
negative 343 including factoring out the
negative numbers or the a negative one
so if we factor out the negative 1 the
first thing we get it's negative 1 times
43. let's think about what other prime
numbers go into 343 2 doesn't go into it
this is an odd number 3 doesn't go into
it if you add these numbers you adds up
to seven that's not divisible by three
that's a quick test for testing
divisible divisibility by three
five doesn't go into it doesn't end with
a five or a zero here let's think seven
is the next prime number let's see if it
goes into 343.
goes into
343. 7 goes into 34
four times 4 times 7 is 28.
subtract 34 minus 28 is six bring down
the three
seven goes into 63 nine times
nine times seven is 63 subtract we have
no remainder so it goes in exactly 49
times so 343 is the same thing as 7
times 49 and 49 is 7 times 7
is 7 times 7. so we can rewrite this
expression up here we can rewrite it as
the cube root
of
the cube root of negative one times
seven times seven times seven or another
way to think about it we could view this
as being equal to the cube root
of negative one
times the cube root
of seven times seven times seven now
what's the cube root of negative one
what number to the third power is equal
to negative one well negative one to the
third power is negative one right
negative one times negative one times
times negative one
is equal to negative one right this is
equal to one then times negative one is
equal to negative one again so that's
negative one and then what's the second
part what's the what
what times itself three times is equal
to seven times seven times seven well
seven
right this is literally seven times
itself three times so the second part is
seven so the answer is going to be
negative 1 times 7 or
negative 7
negative 7. and you can verify for
yourself you take negative 7 multiply it
by itself three times the 7 kind of the
the the negative part you could use this
negative 1 to the third power we'll end
up with a negative and then the 7 to the
third power will give you the 343.